s'installe on monte on dit au revoir à
sa famille à ses amis donc c'est quand
même un moment super émouvant parce que
on sait pas si on allait aussi on va les
revoir quand même à ce moment là donc on
essaie de se dire tout ce qu'on a
tout ce qu'on a à se dire on dit au
revoir à tout le monde sur les marches
de la fusée et puis on monte dans le
petit ascenseur et puis on monte on
monte on monte on montre comme ça et là
grand silence et à la fusée qui fument
qui vibre un peu c'est un peu bizarre
mais moi c'est la sorcière j'ai
l'impression qu'il avait pas de fin en
fait on rentre à l'intérieur et là c'est
ça ressemble un peu un sous marin on est
vraiment on ferme et on ferme des
grosses écoutilles en faire sur nous on
est attaché de partout on peut même plus
bouger on est ligoté en fait c'est
vraiment ça la sensation ça rien à voir
avec un avion on attend le décompte
final
et puis jusqu'à ce que la fusée prenne
feu alors là c'est le tour de manège
ultime ça dure huit minutes 48 et
ensuite on arrive en orbite et là on
regarde pour la première fois par la
fenêtre et on voit le jour qui se lève
et les îles du pacifique et lundi ça y
est je suis dans l'espace
[Musique]
la sortie dans l'espace c'est un peu le
rêve dans le rêve en fait c'est lol
c'est la poupée russe de du vol spatial
ont ça prend énormément de temps et
d'efforts de tout préparer pourquoi
parce que parce qu'il ya du risque en
fait là on va sortir on va se confronter
vraiment aux éléments le les changements
thermique 1 + 100 degrés au soleil moins
100 degrés à l'ombre
l'environnement plus hostile qu'on
puisse imaginer pour l'amour à l'essai
on va s e
ce confronté à ça et en plus avec 400 km
de vie dessous les chaussettes mais
voilà une fois qu'on apprivoise tout ça
au bout de quelques temps dans la sortie
ça devient naturel et puis là-bas quand
on a un peu de un peu de temps et qu'on
peut se dégager les mains du travail
on prend les photos on regarde la terre
est lancée et des souvenirs pour la vie
on a l'impression que c'est une énorme
boule qui défilent sous les pierres ça
passe du désert à la mer etc
donc c'est assez spectaculaire donc ça
laisse des souvenirs et les passages
jour/nuit aussi on est on voit la terre
et puis tout d'un coup on passe du côté
obscur à fond c'est comme si tout le
monde était niée les lumières elle en
voit plus rien du tout on va plus qu'à
deux mètres avec les landes du casque il
ya moins de se perdre autour de la
station spatiale donc maintenant c'est
des choses qu'on peut même pas simulé
sur terre en fait tous les voyages dans
l'espace le mien autant que tous les
autres
les gens reviennent différents en fait
ils reviennent différent parce qu'ils
ont pris un recul qu'on concède pas
prendre sur la terre l'être humain on va
dire et pas fait moi je trouve pour
raisonner adea des grandes échelles
on sait pas on n'est pas capable et pour
ça nous parle pas parce qu'on peut pas
le toucher parce qu'on peut pas le voir
parce qu'on va le ressentir donc on peut
dire oui la température augmente de 2
degrés en x années c'est pas bien mais
quelque part on n'a pas de moyens de
l'expérimenté nous mêmes alors que aller
dans l'espace est passé c'est tout bête
mais on prend le recul nécessaire pour
mettre la terre à l'échelle dont on peut
faire l'expérience avec ses sens en fait
on peut voir les choses on peut voir le
changement climatique on peut tout d'un
coup tout ce cette chose qui me passait
infinie dont vous voyez pas les limites
quand on est sur terre
et là tout d'un coup ça devient très
petit très borné et c'est comme ça en
réalité mais de le voir avec ses sens
c'est très différent qu'on s'inquiète
parce qu'on se dit on fait un parallèle
qui est assez évident mais mais c'est la
terre ces jeunes c'est ni plus ni moins
qu'un gros vaisseau spatial en fait avec
un équipage de quelques milliards
d'individus mais c'est la même chose
c'est le même principe nous on est dans
notre petit vaisseau fragile
environnement hyper hostile ressources
limitées et il faut bien s'entendre et
bien s'en occuper pour que le voyage
dure le plus longtemps possible
la terre c'est exactement pareil sauf
qu'on n'a pas compris c'est peut-être
qu'il faille aller dans l'espace pour le
comprendre mais mais mais quand on a
compris ça on il ya des choses qui me
paraissent évidentes
donc fois qu'on a compris ça on sait
qu'il faut tout faire pour protéger d'un
côté moi j'ai ressenti de l'inquiétude
mais d'un autre côté
moi j'ai ça m'a aussi prouver que c'est
un peu c'est un peu naïf mais que l'être
humain est capable de faire des choses
absolument incroyable